- [Interviewer] All
right, what is your name?
- Ruth, or Esther, I don't remember.
I think I'm Ruth.
- [Interviewer] You think you're Ruth?
- [Ruth] I'm not sure (laughs).
I imagine it though.
- [Interviewer] So Ruth,
tell me about your childhood,
Where'd you grow up?
- [Ruth] Africa.
- [Interviewer] Africa?
- Mhmm.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
Did you grow up with both of your parents?
- Uh, Mr. McConaughey, is that your name?
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Mr. McConaughey?
I did not grow up with my parents, no.
They were there in part.
- [Interviewer] And what
happened with your parents?
- Oh, they enlisted
some aid to care for me.
The aid turned out to be ruthless
in their pursuit of political power.
And so, part of them gaining
political power was to move.
And when we moved, we lost contact.
My family did, with me.
My folks did, I mean.
- [Interviewer] How old are you, Ruth?
- Ten.
- [Interviewer] You're ten?
- Mhmm.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any--
- What'd you call me...?
- [Interviewer] Do you have any family?
I prefer Marcy, but (mumbles)
- [Interviewer] Do, do
you have any family?
- Yes, yup. As a matter
of fact Sissy Spacek
is my sister.
Yeah she did the movie "Carrie",
perhaps you've heard of it.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Carrie had great a
great deal of telepathic
or telekinetic powers.
Um.. telekinesis.
I was stolen from her by her sister.
I failed to return.
I'm going to hunt her (mumbles)
- [Interviewer] Ruth,
where do you stay at night?
Do you stay in a tent?
- [Ruth] In Whoville Alley.
Yes, I live in a tent.
And you're welcome to visit.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- [Ruth] Do we have to summon you a...
Or really? I didn't know that.
You are warlock.
The one from the movie.
Um...
The name Lambert rings a bell.
He played the role of Warlock. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Hold on. Hold on.
Let me ask you a question here.
Do you do any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- I used um, I used something
new called Pyramid recently.
That's an android drug.
It was very bad for me.
It ruined my eye sight.
And you know, it's already bad enough.
It's not really eye sight.
I'm sorry.
But... I used methamphetamine.
- [Interviewer] You used crystal meth?
- [Ruth] Crystal meth. Right.
And I used...
Um... Cocaine.
I also used a little bit
of 'shroom, or angel dust.
You ever heard of it?
- [Interviewer] Yup.
- [Ruth] Um, what they've done is
condense angel dust recently.
Into a compound that
takes life of the bearer.
Or the person that you're mimicking.
And it allows you to
mimic the person almost.
[Ruth Sniffs]
Personal movements. Um tenor.
Timber of voice, that sort of thing.
- [Interviewer] Ruth have you ever been to
any of the mental health
facilities here in Skid Row?
- [Ruth] Yes.
But not under my true
name and form though.
- [Interviewer] And what
happened when you were
at these facilities?
(mumbles)
Have you ever had professional
mental health care?
- [Ruth] Not very. No,
not really. I haven't.
Well not since I was at the facility
featured in "Girl Interrupted".
I think that was in Boston.
It's been a long time
since I've been there.
I've been undercover CIA with my husband
Sean Connery since then.
Since escaping, my--
Enough memory returned to me
that I was able to be drawn away.
(mumbles)
- [Interviewer] How
many years have you been
down here in Skid Row?
(Ruth mumbles)
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
How many years have you
been down here in Skid Row?
- Um, well ten years, I don't know.
A larger portion of my life.
Most of it.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever
take medications for your
mental condition?
- I was considering a couple of 'em.
Leprexa, which is largely
a female estrogen, right?
Yeah, they were
considering giving me that.
I'm willing.
He told me that he was
going to give it to me.
Victor, you want to make that trade.
A bottle (mumbles)
I dreamed that you had me
already, but you didn't.
Like Alice but even smaller.
His but it's only miniature-et.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any
friends on the street, Ruth?
- I have a few.
One of them is uh, Carl.
She's actually Lucy Liu.
I'm Lucy Liu but she's Lucy Liu Junior.
I named her.
And she's actually the
actress behind Lucy Liu's
performances.
(mumbles)
- [Interviewer] Have you
had any bad things happen
to you while you've
been here on the street?
- Many.
- [Interviewer] Many?
- I would say so, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kinds
of stuff happens to you?
- Spiritual rapes have become often.
Well, they're not rapes any more.
I've taken the profession.
But with rape, it was a
period of rape that ensued.
I don't think my parents
understood it as rape.
He wouldn't have understood it as rape.
Maybe he would have.
I think he would have, maybe.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any children of your own?
(mumbles)
Do you have children of your own?
- Um. (laughs)
Yes, I have many.
I have 700.
700 of my own.
Whenever I came to a
servants houses (mumbles)
You mean children of my own,
yeah that's 700.
Then the ones I'm
talking about after them.
You know, could have been,
they're like, they're like
off-children, step away children.
(mumbles)
- [Interviewer] Are you
certain your name is Ruth?
- No, I'm not certain.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think your name actually is?
- I feel a Ruth, they were
sisters and they were friends.
And I don't know, I might not be one.
Someone told me that I was.
- [Interviewer] Esther or Ruth?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] Okay. (laughs)
- I'm not, no okay I'm sorry.
Are you?
- [Interviewer] Am I what?
- One of the two sisters in the Bible.
Esther or Ruth.
They were Kuhumu, maybe.
(mumbles)
They probably were.
You are aren't you?
- [Interviewer] All right, Esther or Ruth.
Thank you very much.
- I have Esther or Ruth
available to me immediately.
Andre and Keith are my two children
that were arrested recently.
I haven't been (mumbles)
You heard that?
Okay, I gotta go.
- [Interviewer] Okay, Esther
or Ruth, thank you very much
for talking with me.
- That's it?
This was fun.
- Oh, what are you gonna do here?
You gonna film a picture?
- [Interviewer] I take
photographs here and do interviews
like this.
- Really? Are we friends?
- [Interviewer] We're friends.
Stop by any time.